well according to recent report here at
Fox Republican Party leaders have a
secret plan to win the 2018 midterms
instead of telling voters what they
would do with another two years in
office they've decided to run once again
against Hillary Clinton the former
Democratic nominee to work last time the
idea is it'll work again the appeal is
obvious nobody really likes Hillary
Clinton even people who are paid to
pretend they like her
the downside is it's not really a
relevant argument Hillary Clinton
doesn't run anything anymore she doesn't
represent the modern Democratic Party
they've moved on to another planet and
that's the point Democratic leaders are
now saying things far more extreme than
anything amid Western Methodists like
Hillary Clinton ever would have said or
thought they become openly bigoted for
example blaming an entire ethnic group
for the country's problems they've
called for eliminating our country's
borders the right to self-defense even
the distinction between male and female
they're at war with nature and with
common sense and by the way they're
agitating for an actual war against
Russia they are insane some of them are
dangerous and somebody ought to run
against them not against the ghost of
some elderly retired nominee from last
cycle it's somehow the Republicans in
Congress say they're not going to do
that are they we have someone to tell us
congressman Jim Jordan is a Republican
represents the proud state of Ohio and
he joins us to take action thank you for
you bet yeah so look I don't want to
poopoo the idea of run against Hillary I
love doing Hillary's segments they're
hilarious they're little mean but it's
fun but the Democratic Party of right
now is not the party of Hillary Clinton
right it's an openly extremist racist
party I would argue and I think it's
obvious that Republicans in opposition
we should run against them but why
aren't they well I think what I would
say is this let's run for what we told
him we were gonna do in 16 let's let's
run on what we've accomplished and I
would argue 17 was a good year
regulations were down the taxes have
been lowered the economy was growing
Isis's backpedaling the Embassy's going
to Jerusalem Gorsuch is on the court
that was a pretty darn good year really
that's why people voted to move the
embassy to Jerusalem there are lots of
Republicans who think that being being
being our best friend an ally in the
Middle East Israel doing something like
that makes sense after all every other
capital in the world that's where your
was a pretty good year so far this year
we haven't been doing what we said this
spending bill we passed four weeks ago
was not what we're supposed to be doing
so let's do what never hurts to keep
your promises
never hurts to do what you told him you
were gonna do and go run on that and run
against what the left the hard left is
pushing in their party I think that's
the winning so if you had a political
party that literally wanted to eliminate
the differences between men and women
and pretend that nature wasn't real yeah
run against that I'm all for it I
haven't ever heard a Republicans
actually men and women are different
that's a biological fact and when you
pretend you destroy society marriage
should be what marriage is always Matty
life should be protected I mean
obviously like they're the Democrats
have got to the point where they are
attacking people trying to get them
fired from their jobs for acknowledging
their biological difference yet between
the sexes
why do Republican on colleges can't but
college campus is not letting people
conservatives Christians they're
anti-semitic stuff on college they're
stopping all those kind of things that
attacking the first and I think we
should camp we had Ben Shapiro Adam
Carolla come in in a committee that I
get the privilege of chair and talking
about what's going on on college
campuses how radical is how anti-semitic
it is how anti-christian is how anti
conservatives and now anti basic basic
fundamental beliefs it is so I'm all for
that as well but let's let's go do what
we told him we were going to do what
they elected us to do in November of
2016 and let's let's show that contrast
with what the radical leftist show and I
agree really the 2016 election if you
could isolate one promise obviously be
the wall courts and we need to do that
and that's been the one consistently
ignored by Republicans in Congress like
yeah just has a massive spending bill no
wall we funded things in that bill we
said we wouldn't we didn't fund things
we said namely the wall it was a 1.3
trillion dollar bill that we had 15
hours to look at 2230 two pages and
guess how long the debate was one hour
one hour debate then we go home for
Easter recess after that we come back we
have four hours to debate a three page
bill balanced budget amendment which is
a great idea but something everyone
knows is not gonna get through the
Congress and become law we debate that
for four hours that's what drives
American voters create they're like
really no wonder they're cynical about
Capitol Hill cynical about Congress
cynical about what they see at this
place so that's the kind of stuff that
has to change cuz again it's not
consistent with what we let's let's
actually fund the things we said we
would like the wall and not fun things
like like Planned Parenthood giving it
giving me your tax off that's ridiculous
we should stop that why would I don't
want you to beat up on the speaker
this way out but why how do we wind up
with a spending bill that funded Planned
Parenthood for half a billion don't know
you know what happened we took three
amendments this is how bad has gotten we
took three amendments to the Rules
Committee the night before that vote one
of them was to deal with the Planned
Parenthood issue and all three
amendments were not made in order and
you know why they weren't made in order
because they would have passed they
would have passed on the House response
who did that
that'sthat's comes from the leadership
telling the Rules Committee you can't
make these things in order because
actually they would pass on the floor to
Paul Ryan is more for Planned Parenthood
than all I'm saying is he's more for
getting something through that the swamp
likes mainly the United States Senate
because the argument is oh if you make
those amendments in order they will pass
the bill will go to the Senate and they
won't pass it well I'm tired of that
let's have the debate and we were so
poised to win Tucker Chuck Schumer shut
down the government over a weekend over
amnesty and the American people said we
don't think that's a smart idea we were
poised to win instead we did what the
swamp always does much more money on
everything Thank You Google a tax cut
perfect congressman thank you you got
that I appreciate it